[Musique]
bon
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
gilles reçu l'aval faire marcher là
à temps ne comptez surtout partir
pourquoi pas mais langil
mais je te jure ça a saigné cic
non
c'était pas les archers sa
peau non qua non mais qu'est ce que tu
sais faire voilà la cuisine - servir au
toit qui fait bien d'autres choses
[Musique]
active et celle que tu veux
les chaînes de cul
[Musique]
bon
youtube organisation
ouah mal regardé un film de cul dans
l'autobus
et bientôt ce sera comme ça d'ailleurs
en fait bah oui on va voir un fragile
enceinte
oui bonsoir au
quatrième étage si vous le désirez ou
bien on joue bien on est là pour moi j'y
crois
a tout de suite
[Musique]
à
ça
la main premières années d'enfance
[Musique]
moi la chose que j'ai hâte de voir ces
os x il va te couper par dix ans ces
toilettes quoi mais qui prend ton
portable tu fais une photo de toi quand
tu fais
ça
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire c'est drôle imaginez les
toilettes 2h10 ont baissé en 10 ans mais
pour tout ce qu'il fait pour
toi non pour moi il va sûrement un beau
soleil sinon sera explosive j'ai jamais
vu ses toilettes j'aime bien je trouve
qu'elle est un extraterrestre non mais
j'y
vois là ça réfléchit beaucoup la
personnalité de quelqu'un
des images
ces classes un très bien
[Musique]
je
si
[Musique]
on chantait
beaucoup d'instruments santiago du lot
qu'est ce que tu racontes excuse moi
j'ai été élégant tout le haut début de
soirée puis la jetée marché sur le tissu
des années de sa trêve j'espère et la
molette se dire
merci un petit souci de
jeu mais pas des bijoux normalement
alors pour cette soirée je me suis dit
c'est pas mal et des bijoux et je me
suis baissé tout ça voilà bien
ce
baiser tout seul entre
repos bah oui je pense qu'il va faire
mais vont être soirée loto
j'étais en train de regarder la
télévision là dessus de succès ce que tu
connais ça ça doit valoir une sortie n'y
avait pas du tout va pas je sais pas
quand même savourer les bons payeurs
bientôt le savoir bientôt
vois rien je sais que ma fille
on entend très très
télé ou ses
intentions un chien de la dernière fois
que tu es venu je t'avais dit de le
faire tchao pantin et entre temps tu as
fait aux abois dit je t'ai écoutez je
vais écouter je suis en fait je suis son
agent ouais ça tape le si tu sais ce que
je voulais que tu fasses depuis toujours
il parle d'un film que j'ai fait un film
sérieux ouais non mais tu n'as eu un
film où ils rigolent pas pendant tout le
film il ya des moustaches comme ça ils
tuent des gens enfin il est très simple
je crois que l acteur un acteur comique
en général merci beaucoup portent ses
portes et la tragédie qui est facilement
qanater ses salines tu sais quoi très
bien c'est génial s'est
arrêté
ben c'est un film qui a pas fait
beaucoup d'encre est d'entrer dans créé
mais c'était pas vraiment fait pour ça
c'est pas vraiment un film commercial
d'abord c'est adapté d'un bouquin
s'appelle aux abois de tristan
bernard
donc c'est un film qui se passe dans les
années
50-60 on sait pas c'est pas très
déterminé l'époque et c'est un type seul
étrange qui est divorcée qui vit seul et
puis qui va commettre un meurtre par
hasard comme un taux comme com
comme l'étranger de camus toi c'est un
type qui se baladent dans sur la plage
dans l'étranger qui tue un type il sait
pas pourquoi et tous les événements qui
vont arriver après il va se retrouver en
prison il va et on va le il va avoir à
l'époque c'était la peine de mort donc
il va être accusé il va être condamné
pardon et il va accepter sa com
une sorte de destin qui l'attendaient
depuis longtemps et ça va presque donner
un sens à sa vie finalement c'est très
étrange comme film c'est triste à pine
trail entrer mais qu est bien implanté
désormais continuer dans ce registre un
nom moi j'ai plutôt envie de faire une
bonne comédie un seul vrai c'est vrai
oui parce que j'en ai fait j'en ai fait
un autre après qui s'appelle riviera
brin tout aussi sérieux avec vahina
giocante voilà et moi j'ai plutôt envie
d'avoir un succès au cinéma
dans la comédie quoi c'est ça qui me
manque un peu j'en ai fait plein des
films mais peu sont restés dans
l'histoire dans un bêta place au sud non
j'étais journée ce soir mais je m'en
occupe où j'écris infiniment ouais bon
bien je crois que c'est la seule
solution finalement vous au théâtre non
mais là j'avais commencé une pièce à 19
heures à 19 heures au rex gauche donc à
8h10 des résultats de commander une
pizza comme je rentre chez toi tu es
tout seul
enfin selon la fille
puis ça y est il
est vrai alors qu'est ce que je fais
appel soir ouais non pas tout le temps
on est bon
mais je dis aussi ça si on pouvait
savoir la vérité
et tous les ans qui a nagé rythme et ses
voisins américains disent ah bon tu dois
savoir quoi si je me masturbe oui toutes
les femmes du monstre urbain c'est clair
tout le temps à venir je lis aussi c'est
moi je lui convient tout le tenir
janvier quoi toi non mais dont tous les
jours j'ai deux jours mais j'ai pas je
suis pas comme un mec je veux dire les
femmes c'est pas comme les mecs quoi tu
vois c'est une fois très inspiré le mec
pour tous et tous les jours la fin de
ces quelque chose de créatif c'est une
inspiration donc c'est moins selon xu
bin oui je crois mais c'est plus intense
doit on se demande si c'est drogba
sexy sam & max et les chansons j'ai fait
une chanson que la tension à 2 oui oui
c'est vrai enfin jamais dans mon bain je
mets la musique des dents de la mer ça
serait un peu fort et voilà sa boisson
créhin
et ça soit excisée je regarde mes doigts
de pied
voici les huit mesures montrant que les
doigts de pieds sur les rocades
sais je suis maintenant je suis divorcée
ça serait mieux investi dans son avenir
ça depuis mercredi non
nous cache des choses aurait été un de
ceux qui est restée mariée le plus
longtemps dans sa profession 16 ans
non je le vis bien mais parce que ça ça
devait arriver sûrement mais
non je crois pas trop non si je m'étais
marié sous le régime de la communauté
donc ça veut dire que maintenant je suis
ruiné ses ruines et totalement henry
n'est jamais arrivé ça comme ma fille
l'autre jour je lui dis je m'intéressais
à pagnol à indy mais moi aussi je
m'intéresse pas chemin pagnol c'est
marrant tu vois là depuis quelques temps
j'ai j'ai récolté tout beaucoup d'infos
sur pagnol beaucoup de documentation sur
sur pagnol tout ça et je crois que je
vais vraiment arriver à trouver comment
on peut rentrer dans l'oeuvre de pagnol
silva blessé avec l'équipe
j'ai une question pour laurent baffie tu
veux pas l'appeler ouais vas-y
je pense qu'il pourra pas y impose que
depuis qu'on se connaît avec laurent on
se pose des questions sur les animaux
oui et je pense que celle là il pourra
pas gagner à
20.8 la question
c'est le télé répondent de leur poser
votre question laurent baffie l'aurait
membres maintenant je joue guéret moi
oui laurence hélie à l'appareil je suis
avec tr 10 sont des petites jeunes
filles
et je voulais te poser une question
quelle est la particularité sexuelle en
fait du corbeau voila j'aimerais bien
que tu me rappelles d'ici là je
t'embrasse et je t'encule
ces transferts français trompés le web
oui c'est clovis et pète
au quatrième étage il vous plaît madame
merci
[Musique]
tu
je restais commencé cette nuit dans un
ascenseur j'ai fait une devenir fou
c'est horrible avec mon cousin jeu
toujours en mars et c'est vrai
je suis resté suffisamment pour venir
blanche j'essaie d'ouvrir les
développeurs comme ça j'avais trop les
boules
tu propos ben
ouais je te jure la montre et zain était
hyper hyper cool les trous et combien
j'avais pensé arrêter entre deux étages
storim j'avais mon table je commence à
appeler et ou non on n'est pas resté dix
minutes mais c'est comme ça
un flingue sur la tempe tu as
l'impression que ça dure pour toi sa me
b
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir
ou bonjour à toi
ensuite moi votre volonté mais peu de
gens se marrent
non pour l'instant non
en prime on est passé par les cuisines
jacques ii
bonjour si c'est toi qui m'a mis dans
cette galère
bon ça va très bien ne marche ça va très
content moi je suis très content mon
producteur et est en train de devenir
vraiment content aussi mais moi ça fait
quelques temps que je le suis ce que je
voulais faire un second film c'était ça
mon but
un second film battu ces sites on fit me
plais kiwi des trains sera là et là
c'est bon oui
ça me fait bizarre de dire ça mais je
tourne quoi j'ai fini le j'ai fini le
serpent
active en écrivant à wes fr eh bien les
charges et pierre richard et dans tous
les films allemands et bien gentiment
ouais non non il est temps que c'est
bien c'est bien ça va j'ai un prieur à
césar ce mec effet le brasier non
exactement
non ce débat de santé bonheur santé
connu l'euroligue à jean leloup
et c'est moi déjà je croise pas les amis
que cela il faut regarder bien les yeux
inquiète pas
fait un film de toi l'autre jour où ça
fait des gros seins oui et c'était
génial mist est magnifique pas
magnifique voilà j'ai un profil qui
t'avait dessin tout terrain va la
laissant comme l'esprit que c'est
impressionnant mais c'est adéquat avec
un aussi pour l'europe ou ch était déjà
poursuit l'aïe pour un histoire d'un
cuistot que c'était une affaire qui
roule deux films j'avais pris way 10 kg
et les saints évidemment étaient des
faux seins parce que même si tu prends
des kilos pas forcément une poitrine qui
te ment aussi est inquiète
oui mais c'est étonnant parce que je
passais je me suis rendu compte que si
si j'étais une femme serait atroce parce
que j'ai passé deux mois de tournage à
nous toucher les seins
français sont des vrais bons coups par
rapport aux italiens parce que je veux
casser un mythe c'est vrai ne serait pas
seulement moi qui le dit c'est souvent
le cas c'est la mi temps française veut
casser un mythe mais en même temps il
touche pas assez les seins et touche
beaucoup mais touche mal à mon avis
voilà
ça fait du bien de se rassurer les gars
est pas une confiance en moi je me dis
pas tiens je suis un super coup quoi
mais je crois pas qu'il y a des supers
cours et des mauvais coups ils croient
que c'est une question d'alchimie mais
très sincèrement je rencontre moi parce
que moi avec ma douche heureux ouais bah
ouais j'ai pu quand même temps 13 ans ah
ouais 13 ans comment ça se fait s'il te
plaît faites moi secret j'en sais rien
on il parlait du parler d'elle chimiques
je vois là c'est un truc tu te rends
compte ça sera c'est bien tant qu'on ne
fait pas chier enfin sur rien n'est
défini on est on est très sympa le
l'usiné ici exact exact très sympa mais
pas farouche en plus
j'ai appris des bourre-pifs
était devenu le mec le plus demandé non
je serai du jardin je suis allée du
jardin les deux lacets je ne sais plus
où tu as mais même ce n'est pas le plus
c'est beaucoup c'est déjà tu dis c'est
ce qu'on aime enfin on peut le dire quoi
comme un acteur et tout ça c'est le
choix coincé accord
quand est sollicitée que tu vois là ça
suscite du désir de faire le bon choix
ça c'est bien dommage moi c'est moi
c'est le truc qui me dérange qu'importe
puisque j'en choisirai choisi
mais c'est en fait ce que je veux pas
faire c'est mais ça c'est très égoïste
c'est un même univers qui se suit toi ça
m'ennuie c'est cette référence pour
choisir un beau coup est donc le choix
tu disais qui est très large aujourd'hui
ben le scénar qui tout d'un coup tu
estimes l'histoire qu'il fait a quand
même sa gelée part ça je n'ai pas vu
quoi mais dis moi t'as pas peur d'en
faire trop non non parce que j'ai pas
carriériste donc je vais pas grand mais
voilà cinquante voix trop qu'on doit
trop quand l'année dernière il ya eu 270
films français qui ont un effet j'en ai
sorti quatre sanhédrin vachement de
place où je ne suis pas quoi on s'est
beaucoup mon nom mais concrètement cessé
d'en faire trousses et si les gens ont
envie de te voir ou pas envie de te voir
j'ai finalement ça c'est pas mon épicier
que sur la place et surtout les
histoires qui font venir les gens mais
sujet
je dis moi pourquoi tellement man des x
de fait le film au moment où tu le fais
tu dis qu'il faudrait qu'ils sortent
maintenant et un an après ses filets les
brigades du tigre c'était très long à
monter un ils ont ils ont mis des années
pour monter ça mais c'est lourd
non on a il d'ailleurs il s'est fait
enfin on a commencé fin mi juillet
et on a terminé notre ère et ils ont
tous montés et tout fait
moi je viens faire ah j'adore ce travail
il est fort le mec là mais j'aurais pas
cru cornu au camp nou et d'un départ
c'est pas le mec il a fait deux films et
qu'ophélie winter tu vois
c'est pas le mec qui va filer du pognon
bongrain troisième tu vois et finalement
c'est vachement bien est vachement bien
réaliser un séjour un film blu ray qui a
de la classe comme les classes et habite
à marseille tout le temps là bas à
moitié moitié ouais en fait si vous
entendez que je suis vraiment marseille
ça veut dire que j'ai pas de travail
je suis beaucoup à paris c'est pas parce
que j'aime paris c'est parce que j'ai du
boulot
monde
oh
je
oui bonjour bonsoir
c'est charles diaz et françois rollin et
la police ont fait moi tout est fait
mais bon j'ai payé mes tâches pour la
perquisition merci marivaux
[Musique]
messieurs en serait soi
ça enfin michel bonsoir
gonthier noir ou blanc
c'est le mot près
oui bien merci
il a financé aucune chaîne n'en vaut au
quai on va se marrer police
aulas
soir
c'est charles birgy la pellicule adrian
newey vous êtes un spécialiste 20
spécialistes je me suis intéressé à une
époque à l'histoire de la pj puisque
j'étais à l'époque chef d'état major de
la pj et comme j'ai
j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans tout ce qui
est une histoire je me suis dit si
j'écrivais l'histoire la vraie histoire
de la naissance de la pj donc entendre
voilà et c'est les brigades du tigre
quoi tout est vrai ce qui se passe en
fait c'est que la pj c'est le dernier
souci des polices à l'époque ouais ouais
complètement le maintien de l'ordre
c'est important la police politique et
l'utilisation des informateurs pour
noyauter tous les milieux un peu évolué
sionards ça c'est drôlement important la
pj tout le monde
voit ça de très loin et pas de s'en
fiche mais il voit ça de très loin
pourquoi parce que c'est une affaire
entre les magistrats et policiers et
comme les policiers sont essentiellement
dirigée par leur ministère de
l'intérieur et par les polices par les
maires et par les préfets la police
judiciaire personnes n'ont fait
réellement et de façon spécialise les 30
donc ce qui fait que à partir du moment
où personne n'en fait pas des voyous il
y en a de plus en plus des affaires
moeurs des meurtres en série et des
bandes organisées les sérieuses douleurs
il y avait des affaires vaches et la
quitter
une affaire de serial-killer
et 1800 les années 1880 voilà un type i
les vagabonds d'accord enfin les
colporteurs d'accord il va de village en
village dans le sud de la france région
de la drôme région de désalpe achats et
où est le type il a il est c'est un
détraqué sexuel c'est un serial-killer
sexuelle est derrière l'équipe
allait draguer
des kilos à des bergers ou des bergères
parce que le sexe bien bordeaux il aisé
ventre
des femmes
cet homme a la particularité
vous avez vu le film juge et l'assassin
la dernière de la série
c'est joseph vacher et ce type a la
particularité d'être physiquement une un
monstre il est capable de couvrir à pied
en un jour j'en avais eu 80 km mais
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous
couvrez à l'époque 80 kilomètres à pied
ça nous a laissé une personne plus
personne ne sait qui c'est produit
hammers
arrête on sait absolument pas qu'on
recherche à madrid d'un meurtrier 80 km
de là à l'époque pour ce type là
heureusement qu'il y avait un juge et un
juge de l'ain qui a dit mais attendez il
ya plein d'affaires comme ça qu'il faut
établir un portrait robot c'est le
premier à avoir pensé à établir un
signalement il a contacté toutes les
polices toutes les gendarmeries qui
avait eu à traiter ce cas là ils ont dit
de mai nous des éléments vous avez
recueilli avec les témoins les matchs en
tout et puis la grâce à ça il a établi
un signalement pas quand un autre juge
il a fait il a diffusé le signalement et
un beau jour le site s'est fait arrêter
et c'est ça que les brigades du tigre
vous mettre en exergue c'était là sa
clovis cornillac
quand est ce qu'on mange ici
tu sais quoi tu devrais faire des trucs
parce que les gens s'ennuient jamais
-
cé
et c'est quoi le jeu va nourrir la
sphère de la mercière de lyon
vraiment
je suis allé je suis allé au 127 un
matin ici c'était un jour d'émission je
faisais bain de minuit il ya six flic
qui sont arrivés dans cet appartement et
qui ont commencé à l'oeil dans tout
l'appartement d'ensuite suis là et je
leur ai dit que c'est joli jouet serpico
vous avez pas mettre des petits paquets
radiateur et ils ont tous fouillés sans
rien trouver ils m'ont amené c'était une
affaire qu'est-ce qui cherchait c'était
la mercière de lyon la faire ces gens
vraiment et la boulangère de nantes
bien sûr il y avait ma niche aux cinq
ans qu'a été dans cette affaire mais oui
c'était la pire des années 80 au milieu
des années 80 tu me rendes à faire dodo
sur l'ado ps qui s'est fait dans milieu
et donc moins il m'emmène là bas donc et
à l'aube crise c'est un enjeu oui
l'office des stups points et donc au
début c'est très sympa c'était un peu
starsky and hutch je le dis franchement
j'ai horreur de continuer l'histoire et
elle commence comme ça parce que chaque
fois pourquoi parce que j'ai horreur des
soirées où on me parle de mes de mon
métier de policier ah ouais le pire
quand on est mais tous les policiers je
crois que c'est comme ça ça que les
soirées ça commence pas alors les
contraventions non moi je vois pas de
confirmation mais vous vous rendez
compte propre ou non nous sommes tout le
temps
mais en histoire
il emmène
au début c'est très sympa c'est un peu
starsky et hutch et voilà on discute un
homme sur dix ans j'avais à l'époque je
faisais de bonnes minutes j'aime bien
votre émission bain de minuit sache
combien tu sois moi je me dis c'est cool
et et après changement de trait qui me
monte au premier étage présente je tombe
sur glace était plus tu as quel âge
c'est kafka mais quand j'étais un dealer
jeter un dealer et m'ont dit oui vous
dirait de la dope et tous types à de la
loppsi si vous dirait de la dope et où
ils font rentrer un mec et ça c'est le
seul truc que je vous en veux pas parce
que vous êtes pour rien mais j'ai pas
trouvé sympa c'est un faux témoins le
mec il faut rendre un mec qui dit
monsieur est ce que monsieur ardisson
vous a vendu de la drogue et le mec du
bruit et la heureusement ce qui m'a
sauvé c'est que j'étais pas coupable
dire que j'ai dit est tombé si c'est
comme ça on va pas tourner l'émission de
cinq jours de tournage de l'émission on
va pas tourner l'émission ce soit en
valais a lyon on va aller voir cette
fameuse mercière de loin et elle va vous
dire que je ne suis pas coupable quand
ils ont vu que j'étais prêt à annuler
l'émission est allé à lyon avec eux
évidemment ils ont compris que j'étais
pas de nouvelles ils m'ont laissé sortir
je sors je bois un coup au micro du
point à saint philippe du roule avec le
flic j'écoutais je travaille pour la 5
cf ans il vaudrait mieux qu'on sache pas
que je me suis fait serrer ou même si à
rien pour une affaire de doctorat et le
mec me dit vous en faites pas monsieur
en piste
le jour même voici j'avais tourné je les
tournées bad minuit
rue du bourg-l'abbé en remontant couloir
sébastopol sur la radio du taxi thierry
ardisson entendu pour une affaire de
dopage hélas comme quoi le pire n'est
pas toujours sûr c'est que robert
absents qui avait pourtant une
réputation de dur accus et l'envié
m'a jamais rien dit j'ai continué mon
émission que je pensais que de virer la
c3 mais d'un autre côté quand ya pas de
nom même savez pourquoi non parce que
j'avais un copain qui lui était vraiment
dans le deal parce que mais pas de fumée
sans feu évidemment que j'avais des
copains que tu es dans ledit et lui m'a
appelé il disait toujours je t'apporte
livre demain ah ouais
[Musique]
ton pourquoi tu tousses quoi et c'est un
artiste qui était vraiment un type très
cultivé qui m'a fait découvrir des
livres formidable il m'amenait vraiment
des livres je comprends ça qui les a
indignés
vue du point de vue des flics je
t'apporte livre demain ou demain je
t'apporte de livres les merlots mais ça
comme quoi tu as dirigé un beau gars
marcellin mais au fond on les bat pour
trouver quand j'ai été inquiété pour
rien
ouais je répétais à l'odéon et je vais
chez des potes tout ça et il habite à
pigalle je vois un coup tout ça à ta ta
ta ta ta ta tu bouffes bien tout va bien
tu descends tu sors tu vas pour rentrer
chez toi
là
oui bonsoir bonsoir c'est noël mamère
raymond j'arrive à la fin voilà les deux
4e étage messieurs s'il vous plaît on y
va merci
je vais pour rentrer chez moi et
j'entends une femme hurle et tu as du
mal on entendra une femme hurler à rien
faire a pas bougé donc tu fais quelques
pas d'elle tue-t-il ça vient d'où pire
est un porche puis sous le support jeu
voilà la porte était un peu toi papa
complètement encore vraiment très très
fort quoi google et donc tu rentres et
joie mais 45 balaye que le toit
gourmette patates et pas toi mais prône
tenant cette femme par les oreilles le
mettant des coups de genou dans le
visage donc tu dis je dis aux gaillards
ça va maintenant je t'ai vu c'est bon tu
arrêter tout ça pas de la même année dit
dégage est tout autre et que tu fais tu
vas sur le bonhomme on s'est battus quoi
année une minute trente vraiment montre
en main très très 20 rapide les flics
arrivent on se retrouve au commissariat
et là tu te retrouves au commissariat tu
dis je vais faire ma déposition tu fais
pas ta des positions leur fuite il
demande d'abord à la dame j'ai su ce qui
est normal la dame et en chant et la
dame dit elle me regarde et me m'a
agressé et il a tapé mon mari et moi
j'avais tapé au visage du mec donc le
midi il porte plainte contre moi pour
coups et blessures et elle pour
tentative de viol il se barre et moi je
fais ma déposition en nylon attendez je
sors chez des potes je répète demain
matin
à l'odéon mec m'a étape et mais ça se
voyait moins d'adrien étape et tu vois
de rythme et tout d'un coup tu es tu
parlais de kafka tu es dans un peu de
casse cas mais qui écoute toi t'es
gentil déjà on bat m oui mais dans le
dans la petite cage je me retrouve dans
la cage et le gros flip commence à
monter la parano commence à montrer
évidemment je sais pas il devait être
cinq heures 5 heures du matin un truc
comme ça il ya un il ya un képi qui
parle je dis attendez moi j'ai je risque
quoi l'analyse par mercury cinq ans
[__] tu démissionnes je serais tu
étudies bonsoir
super pas
vraiment à en
croire
thierry noël si vous avez eu des
problèmes avec la police c'est le moment
alors imaginez vous la police du temps
de les brigades du team par aucune
formation aucune formation tous des
anciens militaires bon je veux dire les
mecs ils avaient connu des périodes
difficiles et quoi et puis et puis bon
une sorte d' idées reçues quoi le type
qui est pas bourgeois
casey qui a eu qu'à une vie sociale
enfin qu'à une vie normale est aussitôt
suspect quoi donc c'est quand même une
autre époque et vous raconter la bande à
bonnot et c'est normal alors oui
pourquoi parce que c'est la grande
affaire
il évalue celle de cette époque là c'est
le
premier est le motoriste exister dans le
film de l'histoire du mondial est la
voiture qu'ils utilisent c'est une de
nos bébelles ville super bagnols pour
l'époque ça va à plus de 100 à l'heure
ce qui est énorme à l'époque et ils
l'abandonnent sur une plage de dieppe et
finalement fait un sens alors
non moi c'est un ancien lycée
élie in avec des vélos à l'écouté a
pris l'année dernière avec des vélos sur
les braises oui
m'accrocher une pub la voiture était
accidentée loin parce qu'il voulait
finir
je dis
donc et donc c'est grâce aux contacts
avec l'étranger que ce soit pour la avec
l'angleterre pour la voiture retrouvée à
d'y être que ce soit pour qui ben sheets
le l'anarchiste russe qui lie à la bande
à bonnot et on va réussir à
l'entraînement dans le film non mais un
peu un peu et
tu fais bien l'art schisteux russe
j'ai le regard de l'homme qui a été
martyrisé par rapport aux systèmes
russes c'est un désir de revanche absolu
sur ses services haut débit les laver et
les affaires des agissements pourcentage
dans la dans les sports les enquêtes des
brigades mobiles c'est un serpent mais
un peu peu pourquoi parce que parce que
les brigades mobiles c'est surtout les
crimes les délits de droit commun
la sphère bonne ont d'ailleurs c'est du
délit de droit commun on dit que c'est
de l'anarchiste et les voyous voyous
teintées d'anarchisme 1 c'est quand même
pour la plomberie fenêtres à johanna je
veux dire alors dans le film je suis
inquiète une de ce point de vue qui est
une fiction il vole pour essayer de
démontrer une énorme escroquerie bonjean
vivre pas plus mais dans la réalité il
vole pour voler quoi et je pense que
enfin ça c'est juste une mais j'ai quand
même le sentiment que qu'un type comme
raymond la science était plus barré là
dedans et que et que dans le mais qu'en
revanche n'était pas un actif et que et
que dieu lui c'est lui le c'est grâce à
lui que
le limage d'âgisme s'est collé à la
bande à brive parce que je parce que
j'adore la bande à bono c'est une erreur
- renault il est pas chef ouais asean
ont un cv la bande à bosser un membre de
la bande simplement comme c'est lui qui
en voiture comme celle qui conduit comme
c'est lui qui répare la voiture comme
c'est lui aussi qui a à choisy le roi va
à ivry et puis après choisy le roi va
tirer se montrait un type complètement
c'est son personnage qui va rejaillir
sur l'histoire de la bande et on va dire
la bande à bono mais il est pas cher
dans youtube ou non c'est vraiment le
chef
s'appelle le chanteur
mais vous allez être étonnés mais vous
savez qu'elle était quelles étaient mes
principales préoccupations à l'époque un
les mendiants parasites des campagnes de
les étrangers à l'état civil douteux
steak les étrangers des italiens ils
venaient partout
centrale beaucoup d'italiens des
polonais à l'état civil douteux je
continue le président de la république
fallières qui annonce qu'il va
systématiquement donné sa grâce aux
condamnés à mort donc cros polémique sur
la peine de mort
les gens des barrières mais les petits
loulous des barrières la racaille des
barrières et puis les campagnes et on
s'aperçoit que dès qu'un fait divers à
l'époque grosse grosse grosse
campagne dans la presse avec des
arrière-pensées politiques parce que ça
va changer en scène gauche radicale et
celle qui est nécessairement l'axis et
c'est incroyable parce qu'on retrouve
tous les éléments qu'on va traîner
siècle
j'ai reçu la visite d'un huissier
à bègles à 8h30 le matin qui m'a annoncé
que tout les tous mes comptes et tous
ceux de mon épouse était bloquée
parce que la société le semencier qui
avait demandé dommages-intérêts aux sept
faucheurs ont été condamnés à toulouse
dont -
a mis à exécution ces dommages intérêts
demandés ce la totalité cent mille euros
et donc leurs obligés de payer ici sans
tomber sur moi
et en l'occurrence ils sont tombés sur
le seul mec qui était député de la
république et député de la république et
qui est appelée au mois de mai à se
prononcer sur une un projet de loi sur
les ogm absolument favorables au second
c'est d'ailleurs elle explique je
comprends pas c'est quoi le problème le
problème c'est de dire
que
nous quand on fauche du maïs est pas de
l'obscurantisme c'est pas pour dire non
au programme le problème c'est qu'on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui quelles sont les
conséquences sur la santé il ya eu un
essai qui a été fait par la société
monte et monsanto sur les rats pendant
90 jours seulement n'a jamais pu
vraiment savoure enfin en on sait qu'il
ya eu des changements sur les rats
important qui n'était pas anodin et ils
ont quand même on a quand même autorisé
ce maïs monsanto on a quand même
autorisé sur le marché attend est ce que
le problème c'est de modifier le maïs ou
est ce que c'est que les graines peuvent
être vendus que par monsanto c'est ça
que j'en ai bien sûr les graines ne
peuvent être vendues que par monsanto ou
que par pioneer celui qui est venu me
chercher mes soixante trois mille euros
un coin de sa cause d'un système qu'on
appelle le brevetage du vivant le
problème c'est quoi c'est que des gens
aient le droit de breveter le vivant le
lait les produits génétiquement
transformés sont dangereuses et les
produits chimiques les deux lits sera
encore plus dangereux du fait qu'ils
sont brevetés et ailleurs par exemple
aujourd'hui en inde tu as des milliers
de paysans qui se suicident parce qu'ils
peuvent pas racheter de semences à
monsanto ils y perdent de l'argent et
ils ont ils n'ont plus assez pour
acheter suicide ça d'accord ça je
comprends tiers les mecs dit ils
détiennent en fait ils s'approprient oui
ils s'approprient il il invente un gène
ça ne s'invente pas ça ça fait partie de
notre corps comme décor d'un d'une
plante donc ils découvrent des
propriétés de jeunes élites et comment
ces propriétés jane ils disent moi je
suis propriétaire du gène banman si le
maquis même planter du maïs normal il
peut plus aujourd'hui ça y est une
histoire extraordinaire qui est une
histoire au canada de ce farmer canadien
qui a attaqué monsanto parce que son
corps avait été contaminée par un voisin
un colza transgénique il à faire il a
intenté un procès à monsanto monsanto
l'aider désolé monsieur maintenant votre
chien il m'appartient parce que si ce
avec quoi je vous ai contaminés j'ai un
brevet dessus donc maintenant vous allez
me payer une redevance sur mon mauvais
monsanto a gagné et monsanto a gagné moi
je considère qu'un choix techniques qui
engage l'avenir d'une société c'est un
choix technique très important d'agir
sur le vivant 1 et bien il ne doit pas
être ce choix ne doit pas être réservée
au jour où semences y est c'est à dire à
ceux qui détiennent le pouvoir
économique et à leurs complices qui
peuvent être le gouvernement les
pouvoirs c'est à la société dans des
bacs c'est même d'ailleurs le grand
privilège d'une société démocratique
c'est de pouvoir dire voilà j'évalue les
risques que je prends et je ne suis pas
pour une société sans risque et donc je
me dis qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que cette
innovation ma porte est ce que ça
apporte un plus au bien-être de la
société ou est ce que ça lui fait courir
plus de risques que davantage si ça le
coup davantage que de risques même
attendre ça doit bien avoir des
avantages ces ogm ça nous avantage
surtout pour les financiers parce que
l'europe est elle si tu veux comme ils
vendent en même temps les pesticides
donc c'est un cercle vicieux et c'est
sur tout les ogm c'est uniquement une
invention pour permettre au tenant de
l'agrobusiness un de mettre la main sur
l'ensemble de l'agriculture mondiale il
ya un petit peu plus d'un petit peu
moins de dix jours j'ai diffusé sur
france 5 un documentaire que j'ai fait
avec jean michel venne manille sur le
commerce équitable
et ce documentaire il se déroulait au
mali sur le coton aujourd'hui il ya une
offensive terrible des grandes sociétés
américaines qui sont aidés par une une
institution américaine s'appelle usaid
qui un peu partout dans les pays en voie
de développement et qui essaient
d'imposer le maïs transgénique aux
producteurs de coton malien et le mali
est le premier producteur de coton en
afrique
si lui aussi objet m'arrive c'est la fin
des petits paysans maliens s'est terminé
alors il va se passer qu'aujourd'hui les
maliens résiste contrairement à leurs
voisins du burkina faso et pour
l'instant il le gouvernement les
protègent contre
alors qu'est-ce qui se passerait cpv
plus de petits paysans maliens et les le
maïs sera détenue par perdre à grandes
sociétés un peu perdue d'avancé rv oui
mais c'est quand à 10h30 père que les
combats qu'on ne mène pas un
en
je pars avec trois segments
oui comme suit ça va beaucoup plus vite
parce que ça refroidit à une vitesse
alors que tu fais françois là tu fais
tes gens des trucs éphémère un musée
éphémère oui donc il y en avait 10 2
prévu j'en ai fait
et cette lors la prochaine c'est un la
prochaine le 30 avril
c'est donc comme d'habitude pour un saut
un soir et un seul là je serai à peine
sur scène c'est une pièce que j'écris
qui s'appelle cinq sur cinq que je
mettra en scène qui raconte je te le
fais très rapidement qui c'est
l'histoire de cinq mecs qui parlent des
femmes un peu très librement comme comme
vraiment entre mecs et simplement petit
décalage c'est que ces cinq mecs sont
joués par simple jolies filles c'est
bien
le seul à une petite frappe sur la
confusion des sexes et d'entendre dire
des propos très
quelquefois même assez macho par des
filles qui n'ont vraiment pas du tout
l'air de garçons issus de roll ça ouais
tu en es où thierry alors toi ça marche
là le truc de polanski ben écoute on a
commencé depuis trois jours c'est un
immense text une grande grande mise en
scène roman polanski c'est ça commence
très très bien il ya un accueil très
chaleureux de la part des gens la pièce
parle du doute combien il faut laisser
le doute et dans la conversation et dans
le débat puisque l'appel part d'un
prêtre que je joue qui est accusé de
pédophilie par une nonne une mère
supérieure dans un collège religieux se
soit polanski qui monte ça la pièce
parle du ragot la pièce parle du ragot
la calomnie c'est un sujet qui le
quittent l'école est bien pour le média
et et je dois dire il l'a monté avec une
subtilité extraordinaire comme vous
comme il le démontre à chaque fois dans
le land dans ses films il a toujours un
angle pour regarder les sujets qu'ils
traitent
grande vous et fantaisie humour et
intelligence et subtilité et alors c'est
quoi l'histoire belle histoire parle
d'un prêtre est en fait c'est une
opposition c'est un opposition entre un
prêtre qui a une façon d'envisager sa
foi et sa religiosité d'une façon un peu
plus cool même si on est en 65 mekerra
c'est un mec cool par rapport aux
enfants etc et une mère supérieure qui
elle est dans la rigidité dans la
discipline et a comme elle supporte pas
la coolitude de ce prêtre elle crée le
grief est ce qu elle induit dans la tête
des gens que ce type pourrait être un
peuple est donné et la pièce parle que
de ça que du ragoût combien une fois
malheureusement que l'organe lancé
passant par les enjeux des ongles très
long une fois qu'il aurait balancé se
dit que les aiglons bah ça y est ce le
fait qu'ils les anglais ont c'est
bizarre est vrai que c'est bizarre ce
type qui laisse sceptique c'est bizarre
mais non pourquoi pas alors tirons là on
lui en aurait pas accusé de ça ça serait
pas complètement passée inaperçue mais
là c'est comme moi voilà conviendra à la
lecture du ragot une vie peut être passé
au crible été détruites effectivement la
pièce alain lalanne réside en ce moment
sur outreau même si la pièce parle dans
la l'auteur l'a écrit suite aux
événements qui sont passés en 2002 à
bord unis où une vague une vague de
prêtres accusés de pédophilie qui a
décimé les la tête de l'église
catholique américaine et la pièce où
elle est sublime c'est que justement on
finit ce spectacle alors chacun défaut
en défense et didot moi je défends ma
mamma mon innocence on finit la pièce
d'or est ce que cette mère supérieure si
horrible zakaria tracy la raison est ce
que ce type si sympathique est-ce qu'il
n'est pas coupable et ça c'est un grand
moment du thé préparé pour le rôle de
l'église un peu j'ai été beaucoup
l'église accompagnée par un camarade
mois qui séparent renault santa maria
qui va souvent à l'église de saint
germain assister au prêche du de curé de
saint germain et c'était très important
de poids puisque moi dans le spectacle
j'ai plusieurs prêche il était important
d'acquérir ce décalage quel con les
prêts les prêtres qui parlent de choses
essentielles mais toujours une espèce de
décalage ça les concerne pas vraiment
mais ils sont très impliqué
émotionnellement dans ce qu'il raconte
non ça c'était très intéressant comme
travail à faire sané pourquoi ils ne
sont pas un tueur et les croyants je
crois je ne sais pas en quoi il croit
surtout voir et puis je crois sans une
entité supérieure tu crois sucre est
aventuré riche mais j'ai très peur des
dogmes voilà tu crois en stanislavski et
je crois dans ce cas seule personne
envahir les croise * et bien c'est un
poids comme elle j'ai eu avec romane
c'est que l'ip et parle beaucoup dans
son travail c'est le premier metteur en
scène que je croise qui parle beaucoup
de ça et souvent que quand tu parles de
ça souvent les français ils prennent
pour un con prennent pour cible tu vois
tu parles et alors qu'on manie parle que
de ça de moman tout moment de mémoire
sensorielle de moman before de toutes
ces choses qui sont importantes quand tu
construis un personnage et quand tu joue
la comédie et là c'est la première fois
je parle avec un metteur en scène qui
parlent le même langage et je peux dire
c'est tellement rare que je le remercie
c'était une expérience très commun on
s'était rencontré les deux ans au
théâtre marigny où je jouais a signé
dumas ouais vous jules lui avait mis en
scène et d'accabler dans la salle d'à
côté et on était venu voir si mme dumas
et m'avait fait par deux pas de son
intérêt pour le travail et puis bon
celui-là c'est arrivé d'un seul coup
comme ça et j'en suis ravi
savoir est ce que c'est vrai je regarde
tous est ce que c'est vrai que pour
faire ce métier ou chez eux non non non
ça je crois pas le même pas 1 secondes
c'est ça m'intéresse maintenant à nos
intérêts le truc intéressant de ce
métier c'est génial il n'y a pas de
règle donc on est d'accord mais est ce
que parce que je me confronte à ça
aujourd'hui est ce que le fait de
connaître certaines familles parce que
bon c'est quand même ce métier est basé
sur des familles est-ce que ça c'est
fondamental
j'ai à présent sa france on est un peu
restions au système 19ème siècle la peau
des salons cité dans vos salons bars ça
se passe plus pour toi
convaincu si l'on sait que ça va pas
dire que c'est impossible mais
franchement est plus long il arrête ça
c'est sûr mais si tu as du talent tapas
souci est de faire un
moi j'ai pensé ça est ce que tu crois
est ce que tu crois qui est auteur peut
se dire j'ai du talent je crois pas
qu'un acteur quoi si on négocie on n'est
plus moi je sais ce que je peux faire je
sais ce que je peux pas faire
mais thierry c'est vrai que tu as eu une
petite période de creux absolument et
j'étais juste envie j'avais juste en
nous mettre la tête dans les murs je
m'en souviens c'était rien j'aimais
toujours j'ai toujours une bonne cote
c'est pas pour moi mais les gens étaient
vraiment quel acteur mais moi de ma
réalité c'est que [__] je bossais pas
juste une belle envie de me mettre la
tête dans le mur mais qu'est ce qui se
passe [__] et se passe rien il ya eu
des grosses pensez vraiment oui je me
souviens on a invité pas et en plus mais
en plus son jeu et en plus quand je
venais mais on se donne encore plus
quand je venais j'étais tellement
terrorisée par ce que je dis c'est le
moment faut que je sois là
vraiment c'est non qu'est ce que ça t'a
amené cette télé réalité là alors moi je
fais des erreurs du fond c'est du faux
que des trucs et my mind est une fête
qui aujourd'hui je suis ici avec vous et
j'ai pas eu droit aux cinquante invités
annonce était célibataire et 8 mai
dans les brigades du tigre je savais
qu'ils avaient hésité entre entre
edouard baer et moi ils ont pris edouard
baer parce que c'est la logique
commerciale du cinéma quoi tu vois ce
que je veux dire il ya nombre entêté
dans des dents les papiers quoi à une
époque avec dieudo une année j'avais
tourné cinq films ces cinq films se sont
plantés donc appris ça a été
pompée et surtout quand tu es quand est
il déjà une vedette
voilà c'est la grande différence c'est
que toi tu étais une vedette taient une
vedette parce que one man show une
vedette parce que tu es dvd une vedette
parce que tu fais rire tout le monde
donc maintenant le truc c'est comme si
tu devais passer ailleurs pour dire je
suis aussi acteur c'est comme avec
l'album et je peux être aussi une
vedette au cinéma non mais tu commandes
du coup c'est encore autre chose c'est
le gars à temps avant d'ouvrir la porte
mon van toi c'est comme si moi demain je
dis et je vais faire
si toi j'attendais casser les jambes en
main sur les coins j'attends qu'un truc
c'est te péter les genoux et d'avoir une
salle qui fait
date aurait pas dû voilà c'est drôle on
a ri cas pas entendu peut-être parce que
là on il ya un retour avec la salle un
peu bizarre mais c'était très très drôle
c'est pareil il faut payer un truc bien
sûr mais il faut que tu te trouves et
puis c'est tout qu'est ce que tu veux
faire
douter je pense résolument fait pas non
franchement je m'en fais pas je crois
pas je suis pas encore à la strada comme
serena
mais est ce que tu sais pourquoi on te
demande beaucoup au cinéma en ce moment
clovis pourquoi comment tu expliques ça
non mais ma gauche angoisse par rapport
à salses et c'est justement de 2,2 me
dire est-ce que ça a à voir avec un
phénomène de mode et mon nom wes absolue
c'est se dire que je me sens pas
quelqu'un de la mode étudie ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui tu es dans un mouvement
très demandés et tac qu'une angoisse
c'est à dire moi je faisais salon fait
ça depuis plus de 20 ans combien de
temps ça va te dire non il s'est surtout
ce qui est pas des quais pas d'erreur
sur ceux qui croyaient du succès lui en
ce moment je vis en ce moment enfin
c'est comme du jardin ils ont des
physiques français et c'est à dire
qu'après tout une époque du cinéma où il
y avait des bruns soit sépharade soient
italiens soit d'un seul coup c'est de
retour et français
merde
et on a une on est prépondérant
pourquoi est ce que ça veut dire ça
va on se demandait on se demande notre
âge
57 sais pas
mais tu fais des trucs sympas du film
suit john à l'époque de rené coty mois
vincent réaliser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quel est le même chez toi non 57
je suis né le 27 du mois sa journée tout
vient nos grands parents à 57 à quoi il
ressemblait
si c'est la toile à 40
38 de toi et toi at 8 les toits 27
victoires et mieux c'est pour qu'ils
cinq ans le coeur je suis attirée en
fête jehan de 42 au quatrième étage s'il
vous plaît merci
allez
tkt
le bambou ministre est
tu fume des cigarettes
l'écraser
il attendait ça
m de vu quand même
bonsoir oui bonsoir
ça se passe non messieurs
gérer ou non je joue un truc que je veux
que j'adore qui s'appelle dieu habite
düsseldorf ce qui est écrit que savait
pas mais c'est un malade mental
sébastien thiéry j'ai vraiment la
frappadingue j'ai un tas de copains qui
sortent en disant ce type et ce type est
malade et faut le soigner il ya il a
écrit un truc de browse un gars de chez
total en gros c'est vraiment un truc
comme ça c'est typiquement le genre de
machin qu'il faut pas monter parce que
ça et voilà et du coup c'est beau et
tous les soirs et soutenir la grèce
assal n'est pas énorme certes
non c'est un truc de fou furieux alors
c'est aux petits mathurins
mais trois sur scène et donc ça fait
plaisir ce que c'est d'abord quand j'ai
reçu la brochure du habite düsseldorf
étudie le make up par jour et quand tu
ouvres s'est séparé
j'étais à 100 choses incroyables qui
m'arrivait il ya quoi il ya quinze ans
au débat je n'avais pas ma main je suis
obligée de me mettre c'est rue dans le
cul chaleureux des pages un peu choqué
maintenant bon je préfère avec
applicateurs ne cache pas été un peu
mais pas trop ça très difficile quoi
c'est très compliqué
nana et arrivèrent en a nous a sauvé la
vie on se voit pas à travers la culotte
non je me sens très libre at il juste
que je peux faire du tennis et je peux
jouer à partout et ça sent bon et ses
bleus
qui se promène dans la vie comme dans
les rayons bien su cacher
neuf voix de paris que les vitrines
est ce qu'il est
jusqu'au
je n'ai
toi qui te femmes
à 50
m
non j'étais là
jeulin collerette us
en prenons bien
comment
[Musique]
shatner rêve
voir que vous allez
[Applaudissements]
attendant ce jour est excitant bas
j'aime les gens
qui ont foi en la grande
cyril est clair vite jeu en vaut la
peine
il ya ceux qui tombent on
c'est moi par semaine ya ceux qui
abusent dehors qui est à
jamais je ne sais il traverse compagne
conte
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu